and she's had the tournament of her life
and so close to being the winner of the
World Cup
having winning positions in the
classical in the first game and I think
she's gonna just throw in the towel now
Rosa it's heartbreaking to the tone but
it's kind of heartbreaking because she
would have become a grand master had she
of once I say yeah
of course she will too yeah she she
would be Grand Master in the matter of
next tournament without a Shadow of
Doubt but you want to get that straight
away okay I mean yeah this is not that's
just handshakes on Alexander is the
winner of the 2023 fide Women's World
Cup
for salimova what a run this has been
what a tournament this has been she has
confirmed her spot in the candidates
with a heartbreak ending for the 20 year
old